どうですか
youtube が実日本じゃないですか
そうさ俺今日から youtube カチッよ
また寝ちゃった国になっちゃうんですけど
haribo の買えるわけです
帰ら食ったことないなぁ
pledge 漫画で350円です
爺ちゃん
そいつ号です読めませんん
なんかハリ坊さんもちょっと
らしいですね
おかしいつじゃ嬉しいですけど帰れ食った事ないし
[音楽]
けどこの前のタイヤが組合側ます佐藤
思いましょう
[音楽]
ああああああん
お告げ1234567結構たくさん入ってます組自体は結構綺麗なエメラルドグリーン
的な
までですし見た目はもう帰るです
何とも言えないですねー
ちょっと固めの組だと思いました
まずはテイスティングでしょ
あんまり
悪いようじゃないです
美味しいんじゃって入れって美味しいのか
ちょっといいか食べてみようと思います
方
矢部耐えるの食感て感じましたん
a 動員
謎
無駄に硬いから買えるっぽい
うわぁ
味はいいんですけど
わっ
味はいいんですけどなんか食感が買えるです
じゃあ何か嫌な気分だう
[音楽]
eme
なんか
食感が買えるです
これたぶん食わないとわからないよはっはっはっ
[音楽]
何か変えるだブザー気分なんですよ味は美味しいんですよ
食感がいい
rem ん
なんか申し訳ない気持ちになってきたら伝わらないと思うんですけど
速乾がすごい変えるかんでる数ですよね
カエルの配合
ヴィレッジヴァンガードで売ってるぜひ使ってみてください
美味しいですよ美味しいんですけど
な食感でもっ
カエル感動もないんですよ
全部食うのにすごい
時間が下がりそうです
ぜひ買ってみてください
じゃあ
[音楽]